[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département tout de suite
l'actualité en chiffres 25 millions
d'euros par an sur la période 2021 et
c'était la baisse annoncée pour les
fonds posei par l'europe
serge hoareau vice président du
département délégué à l'agriculture et
l'interprofession se sont rendus à
bruxelles
ils ont obtenu un accord sur le maintien
de ces fonds pour la réunion
le programme d'options spécifiques à
l'éloignement et à l'insularité regroupe
des mesures visant à compenser
l'éloignement géographique des régions
ultrapériphériques dans le développement
et la diversification des filières
agricoles
on vient de gagner une victoire sur l'
enveloppe poesy une enveloppe qui était
annoncé en diminution de 3 9% grâce à la
mobilisation des interprofessions que
nous avons accompagné grâce au travail
effectué par euros d'hommes et le député
européen et younousse omarjee nous avons
pu obtenir le maintien de cette
enveloppe
après une année de mandature
le bureau du conseil départemental des
jeunes fait le bilan de ses actions
menées sur le terrain de grandes
thématiques comme le harcèlement
scolaire et la sécurité routière ont
marqué l'engagement de ces jeunes
collégiens de 5e de quatrième et de
troisième que pour ma part les actions
qui m'ont le plus marqué et les actions
les plus grandes
ça a été la sécurité routière ce qu'on a
fait intervenir des mets simples et de
psychiatres par un médecin
pédopsychiatre la gendarmerie nationale
la vice-présidente de l'éducation et le
président du conseil départemental est
venu pour vous dire que c'était une
action très importante et très
médiatisée je pense qu'on a beaucoup
appris et ensuite il ya eu une action de
sensibilisation contre le harcèlement
chose que ça aussi ça a été une des
grosses actions qu'on a fait est une des
actions les plus importantes
ils lui sont 650 réunionnais tous
demandeurs d'emploi à partir travailler
en métropole le cnar mais ses
partenaires dresse le bilan de ce
premier semestre
de recrutement le comité national
d'accueil et d'actions pour les
réunionnais en mobilité et le premier
facilitateur d'emploi en mobilité sur le
territoire nous mettons en oeuvre des
dispositifs d'accompagnement concret
qu'ils soient humains ou matériels
puisqu'on prend charge billets d'avion
on prend en charge les deux premiers
mois d'hébergement etc
quand vous avez que nous prenons en
charge évidemment la mise en relation
des entreprises pour les entretiens de
recrutement prenons en charge des
réparations mobilité quand nous faisons
tous là bas nous nous sommes j'allais
dire passer le k formant un huit styles
et nous sommes d'ailleurs unique en son
genre sur le territoire métropolitain et
domiens le jeune il est gagnant parce
qu'il est accompagné il est fort mais il
est vraiment bichonné par les équipes
d'une arme le territoire également s'y
retrouve puisque notre taux de chômage
baisse 2000 départs par an ce n'est pas
rien avec un coût qui est moindre entre
6000 et 10 mille euros par jeune c'est
vraiment ça défie toute concurrence et
je crois que le territoire est également
gagnant parce que le jeune il et il se
sent plus fort il est plus ouvert sur le
monde
les entreprises sont contents d'avoir
des jeunes qui sont formés et qu'ils
sont plus compétentes
[Musique]
l'opération nationale partiront livre
s'est tenue pendant deux jours au jardin
de l'état
préparé par la bibliothèque
départementale il s'agissait de se
rendre au plus près des vacanciers de
leur faire découvrir la lecture et les
ateliers de loisirs créatifs
alors ça fait partie de nos missions la
bibliothèque de proposer des animations
hors les murs d'aller vers les publics
les plus éloignés de la culture
nous allons à l'hôpital nous allons au
sein des familles qui ont quelques
difficultés avec le livre nous allons
bien sûr dans les jardins nous sommes
présents lors de la manifestation habib
et eu vraiment sortir de notre
bibliothèque et être sur tout le
département c'est une volonté que l'on
que l'on a et si vous aimez la lecture
et souhaitez participer à la grande fête
du livre pour la jeunesse
rendez vous le mardi 17 juillet à
l'espace vert sous les kiosques à côté
du case de l'espérance à sainte marie le
bon plan de la semaine c'est l'opération
partir en livre avec la bibliothèque
départementale
[Musique]